six one seven eight three zero 47 50
just checking in with people seeing
we're back from fourth of July let's go
to the eight four five area code eight
four five what's on your mind hey this
is Mark Benjamin first off I want to
give you props on that question you
answered from Tim cool sweet about
health care okay yeah I don't think the
audience has no idea what you're talking
about but there was a tweet but it
doesn't feel right yeah no I know but I
think that yeah and you yeah
tweeted him something about I did you
gave him a very good response he also
liked the response I just wanted to give
you props for that as a quickie think
and the next two questions are actually
questions okay this question is can you
make a series on like not just crypto
currencies but investment and just
financial stuff too because I think
there's lots of right-leaning outlets
that are doing something along those
lines but a lot of people I think
neither but help or a bit direction to
understand how how to keep themselves
financially stable or safe
yeah because medicare-for-all and and
ubi is kind of like a dream I got you so
I'm saying I've thought about this
people sometimes will request this mark
here's the concern I sort of make an
effort on the show always to say I'm not
giving financial advice like sometimes
I'll talk about what I do or I'll talk
about what I consider to be best
practices you know prioritizing having
an emergency fund and sort of
understanding elements of not trying to
time the market or why index funds would
you know what all this different stuff
but I always say this is not actually
financial advice for anybody in
particular I worry that if I actually
start doing segments where I am saying
here is actual advice but just know it
might not be good advice for you
personally and like you should always
consult with a fight I just worry that
then it's like well no I am now giving
financial advice and usually that's the
whole thing that I'm not
financial advice Oh as long as you do
that disclaimer I think you're safe
a lot it recently a lot of youtubers on
the crypto end of things does something
long felt like this is not financial
advice yeah and they give like this
doesn't might not apply to etc etc but
if you do like more interviews along
those lines or something that like would
help the people that are on the bottom
kind of keep themselves solvent or honor
or or have some ideas yeah to help them
crawl out of it because I think you're a
really good teacher and I think that you
might be able to pull that off and the
last question will be relatively quick
do you think that we should do Paula
some answer political questions on the
left and the right within the idea of if
things get to the extreme I don't want
this hitting me in the back because we
don't exactly know it's a populist right
worse than Trump happens or a populist
left more of that that is relatively bad
chops up that you know uses mark I don't
understand that last question and I want
to give other people a chance to talk so
I thought I got one answer at least and
we'll we'll try again on that last
question next time I appreciate the call